bonjour benoît prat merci d'avoir à
diriger notre invitation alors on vient
de le dire la capitale voilà qui est
menacée de voir beaucoup de ces hôtels
fermés en tout cas on parle des trois
quarts des hôtels qui risquent de mettre
la clé sous la porte d'ici le mois
d'août
qu'en est-il dans l'aveyron est ce que
vous constatez également cette tendance
alors déjà sur le seul mois de juillet
on est sur une baisse d'activité
significative et un aviron même en
aveyron et aujourd'hui on a surtout un
gel des réservations pour le mois d'août
avait que des gens qui attendent les
nouvelles et encore une fois ce nouveau
décor c'est surtout des annonces sont
faites et aujourd'hui on a encore
concrètement aucune décision ferme et on
ne sait pas demain comment on pourra
accueillir nos clients alors justement
le passé militaire va concerner les
hôtels qui disposent d'une partie
restauration mais je pense que la quasi
majorité des hôtels ou des services de
restauration comment est-ce que ça va se
passer justement
mais aujourd'hui j'ai c'est vrai que sur
la partie restauration il y aura le pass
anitea ce qu'on ne sait pas encore s est
quand même quelques jours de l'arrivée
c est ce que le passager reçoit
obligatoire par exemple pour les petits
déjeuners
on imagine que oui mais on n'a rien de
précis par contre pour venir à l'hôtel
il n'y aura pas d'obligation à
aujourd'hui
mais on est toujours prudent aussi parce
qu'il peut y avoir des annonces un corps
et d'évolution et quand on vient à
l'hôtel souvent bien en termes de
restaurants lorsqu'on a appris avec la
crise c'est à être agile et à s'adapter
donc c'est vrai que par exemple sur du
room service et sur des plateaux en
chambre on va aller les reptiles et pour
permettre à nos clients de pouvoir
prendre un repas entre avec des traders
locaux donc des bons produits
donc on pourra accueillir les clients
dans des bonnes conditions je rappelle
aussi que l'on nouveau les auteurs
beaucoup investi sur toutes les mesures
sanitaires elles toutes les équipes ont
été de former on s'était tous préparés à
faire une grosse saison mais on s'était
aussi tous ceux bien préparés à
appliquer tous les gestes barrière donc
on a mis en place on a beaucoup beaucoup
investie de temps et d'argent
les clients dans de bonnes conditions le
gouvernement avait également
en place des aides aux entreprises face
à la crise sanitaire
on sait que à la rentrée le fonds
solidarité le chômage partiel l aide aux
coûts fixes devraient disparaître
voilà des mesures qui vont être levés de
quoi vous vous inquiétez également alors
je pense vous contre l'entreprise
aujourd'hui des sur quels aspects
financiers mais aussi un effet
psychologique
on vient de dire 18 mois de crise bon la
première fois ça a été dur mais on s'est
remis
on a appris en s'adapter s'il ya eu des
mesures dead qui ont aidé les salariés
qui ont aidé les entreprises donc et on
n'oublie pas que nous on est quand même
tout cela aussi pour combattre ce virus
est la priorité aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe et qu'on s'était préparé à faire
une grosse saison on avait on avait
rebondi oms était remonté et la halle
annonces de la semaine dernière un gros
choc psychologique au niveau de beaucoup
de dirigeants et de beaucoup de
responsables et même dedans salariés de
peux vous le dire
donc bien sûr qu'il ya ces aspects
financiers mais l'aspect financier on
est sur des mois d'activité très fort
pour nous où habituellement on est quand
même sur les mois où on refait la
trésorerie et les aides on ne n'y aura
pas droit parce qu'elles sont aime
beaucoup plus restrictive que ce
qu'elles ont pu l'être par le passé
aujourd'hui c'est ici que tout ce que le
fc financer c'est vraiment là c'est
psychologique de nos équipes qui nous
inquiète justement vous parlez
voilà de ce cet aspect psychologique on
sait que beaucoup de français avait
décidé de changer de métier justement
après sa crise sanitaire des gens qui
étaient en première ligne qui ont été
obligés de fermer à cause de la pandémie
est ce que voilà c'est vous avez observé
également cette envie de changer de
métier de quitter le secteur de
l'hôtellerie oui beaucoup de gens nous
ont quittés alors dont de nombreux gens
si on a aussi des gens qui quittent les
grandes villes et qui viennent qui
viennent rejoindre renault rno région
qui sont quand même avec une qualité de
vie très agréable mais où il y en a
beaucoup de départs et on est en pénurie
de main d'oeuvre
parce que des gens en fait n'était pas
habitué à rester sans rien faire donc on
découvert d'autres métiers et on est
couvert à d'autres qualités de l'ipj je
pense que certains brevets ne rompt pas
ce que ils seront manque de certaines
chansons et c'est à nous aussi d'attirer
de nouveaux talents
on se met en place un point nous
l'apprécions beaucoup de choses pour
attirer de nouveaux talents
donc oui un plus dupes hassani terre va
nous pénaliser
déjà qu'on était un manque de main
d'oeuvre ça va encore accentuer les
choses merci beaucoup en tout cas benoît
prat d'avoir témoigné ce matin sur notre
antenne
je vous en prie alesi et on nous
accueille avec plaisir la kings hôtels
en france et en province merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes propriétaire
d'hôtels en remet à vie